i'm the one who reacts breaking bad
medical scenes here we go
what
the hell is this hey veggie bacon we're
watching our cholesterol i guess not me
i want real bacon
this feels like my struggle right now
because i'm watching my cholesterol it's
more about decreasing the amount of
saturated fat in your diet decreasing
fatty foods fried foods and also at the
same time increasing your insoluble
fiber
[Music]
oh no don't paint don't be
if you're ever feeling lightheaded the
first thing you should do is get down on
the floor the biggest danger of passing
out is actually hitting your head and
causing a subdural hemorrhage so please
if you're feeling woozy get down get
support call for help this is so
embarrassing i am fine honestly
it's just some bug going around first my
wife had it then my son and now me it's
just
it's just like a
chest cold see it's important to not
minimize your symptoms is it possible
that he has a chest cold sure but why in
the world did he pass out from standing
that needs to be further investigated
and it needs to be investigated by an er
team because he could be having a heart
attack for all they do lean forward for
me would you
[Applause]
mr white are you a smoker
no
never
why do you ask
okay this is where these shows things
get a little ridiculous the paramedic
with the power of a stethoscope can
diagnose that there's some really
serious issue going on like lung cancer
at most you can hear lung sounds that
can happen as a result of a pneumonia of
a viral infection an inflammatory
process a tumor but you can't know that
without scanning so this like devious
mischievous look of him going
by listening with the stethoscope is
pure ridiculous
[Music]
[Music]
mr white
yes
you understood what i've just said to
you
yes
lung cancer inoperable
i'm really glad they're showing this
part when you're receiving bad news it's
really difficult to comprehend you just
got a diagnosis that you're potentially
sick for the rest of your life we're
gonna lose your life earlier than you
expected you're not gonna be okay so
what are the next steps of what i should
do so whenever you deliver bad news as a
doctor you have to have the patient come
back you have to have someone with the
patient to help them understand what's
going on this part could be the most
accurate part of the first season lung
cancer inoperable i also don't know how
they realize that it's inoperable so
quickly
a little bit out there i don't know how
much time has passed here it's it's a
little inaccurate it's just
you've got mustard
on your
this is almost like a dissociation
process where to escape from the bad
news he's reverting back to like a
childhood state or a less serious state
and thinking about the mustard because
that's more fixable in the given moment
this does happen maybe this is a little
bit more exaggerated though
eisenberg says relax
i'm relaxed
i'm relaxed
damn man look at that look i'm not
surprised if he broke a few knuckles
hitting a skull on the floor like that
over and over again remember when you
punch someone standing up their head
moves back so there's no excess force
placed on your knuckle in your bone but
when they're laying down and you're
hitting them you're essentially hitting
the concrete with your bare knuckle
you're breaking stuff
how's it bark
what's the matter with you looks like
he's having a seizure sometimes that can
happen with brain bleeds
there's there's no uh a pulse
after there's no pulse you got to start
chest compression chest compression
chest compression do something
do something he he needs an ambulance he
needs a hospital do something you're
smart right do not do that thing he
knows that thing but the thing is really
meant to buy you time it doesn't
actually restart the heart the point of
doing the thing is so that the ambulance
has time to get there and actually
intervene
beans
castor beans
so what are we gonna do with them we are
going to process them into ricin you
actually process it into castor oil and
the residue has ricin in it rice and
beans
ricin he said rice and beans i forgot
about this it's an extremely effective
poison it's toxic in small doses also
fairly easy to overlook during an
autopsy it is checked for an autopsies
by the way especially if there is a
suspicious cause of death
[Music]
this is fugue state what's the last
thing you remember
uh well i
was driving home
i think
from what i remember he's faking this
and he's doing a really good job isn't
it possible that this had something to
do with all the prescriptions i've been
taking in order to diagnose a medication
side effect like that it really has to
be a diagnosis of exclusion where you
rule everything else out that could
cause this dissociative state of his and
then you can then blame the medication
but you absolutely do need a psychiatric
consult here would you tell me about
patient confidentiality
it's very straightforward without your
permission i can't disclose anything you
tell me to anyone what about my family
not to your family not to the police not
to anyone
the only exception would be if you
threatened to kill someone then i'd be
able to tell that person but only that
person protected health information is
really important in the cases of
homicidal or suicidal ideation we do
alert the authorities or loved ones i
don't know that in a homicidal situation
if you threaten to harm one other person
they only tell that person i think they
have to notify the authorities as well
jesse
wake up
jesse
wake up
that is a needle
and a syringe likely to have been used
for
narcotics
[Music]
oh no if someone's throwing up on their
back you have to put them on their side
in order to help clear their airway
because if they can't protect their
airway because they're unconscious they
can aspirate the vomit choke died
dude you gotta act
it is unfortunately how a lot of
overdoses do end someone ends up
aspirating and choking to death
oh that's gotta hurt
that's one way to crush your femur
create a fatty embolism make it go to
your lungs and you just die instantly
also don't forget crush injuries release
a massive amount of electrolytes into
the bloodstream from the damaged cells
and create a complete mashup of your
electrical system in the body which most
importantly happens in the heart
therefore could be lethal
[Music]
how come like bad guys in movies always
walk so calmly like they're never in a
rush
like my guy you don't think the cops are
coming after you just lit up a parking
lot
[Music]
no
[Music]
again the bad guy's down to rush
he lit up a supermarket he's not in a
rush he's getting his axe
an axe to the head is incompatible with
life
gsw to the head incompatible with life
thought i thought i'd let you guys know
no imposible
safiro angelo
hello
induction of vomiting for poison can
work it has to happen very rapidly
remember ricin gets absorbed very
quickly into your mucous membranes
that's why it can affect you even
through your eyes can you make it less
lethal if you vomit it up yeah probably
[Music]
[Music]
i feel like if this was true ricin there
would be a lot of vomiting here
those are pixas machines those look very
legitimate
like a full operating room in there
those hospital beds are so extremely
expensive you have no idea
[Applause]
i mean you have to intubate him you have
to make sure his heart's not stopped
these are the most crucial moments in
order to help save someone's life
oh i have no idea what he just squirted
into his mouth
all right and she's bagging way too fast
when you're bagging you need to bag at
the same rate that a person would
breathe if we're at rest you're bagging
you could actually create a bigger
problem
they're doing an intubation it looks
like
some leads that aren't sticking well
starting ivs all good stuff
oh they're doing dialysis
to get rid of the poison wow
that's a blood transfusion
oh negative blood
universal donor
oh
gracias i love that he's chilling
already not realistic
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe i was wrong
[Applause]
i love how the staff run in no concern
that there's another explosion that's
about to happen
oh okay yeah he's not fixing his tie
that's ridiculous this isn't batman
did you know that i'm a youtube boxer
now click here to check that out i
literally eat punches and give them away
so always stay happy and healthy first i
beat then i treat
[Music]
you